it was natural to move to cultural
marxism
uh an italian communist named antonio
gramsci
came up with this theory um
that the the attack on the class system
was misplaced
we should be attacking leftists should
be attacking the culture
and as it happened the vietnam war came
along
and the left didn't want to fight the
communists in vietnam so they
stayed in the universities and became
professors
and they made this the curriculum
cultural marxism is the menace that we
face today it's pure racism identity
politics it's also called is pure racism
black people good white people bad but
of course it's not
all black people that are good if
they're conservatives
then they're raised right traitors
but you know today's generations don't
have the
basic knowledge for example when i came
out of the lift
um i i we we had been attacking america
and when i saw how evil the left was i
took a second look at america
um and i it was an ingenious
political system they created of checks
and balances
and what i described in my new book the
enemy within is how the democrat party
you look at the democrat party over the
last decade
they are systematically destroying the
american political system
the system of checks and balances if you
pack the supreme court
you eliminate the independent judiciary
and legislators
not only appoint the supreme court
justices but they
um they get to make any law they want
unconstitutional or not they've attacked
the
voter id this is racist
the democrats claim that poor black
people are too
stupid to get a photo id
you can't get food stamps without a
photo id you can't get welfare you can't
get prescription drugs you can't get
into the democrat convention
and if it were actually the case which
it's not since blacks are voting in
record numbers
that voter id was a problem the solution
is really simple
you set up a government agency to
provide photo ids to any american
who asks for one and deserves one that
is their citizens they're not dead
they haven't moved to another state the
democrats never propose this
they just want to eliminate voter id
because they
are determined to create a one-party
state
which is the last sentence of my book
it's not about trump
uh it's not about winning one election
it's about establishing a one-party
state
and the term for these people is
fascists or communists it's the same
thing
that's the appropriate term uh for
nancy pelosi and uh and by in the biden
white house
they're they do what fascists do
they attack they demonize their
opponents
if you're a republican according to
nancy pelosi you're an enemy of the
state
how how much clearer do you need to hear
it from them
that they're fascists i hope you enjoyed
that clip from the ben shapiro show
sunday special if you did
go ahead and hit the subscribe button so
you stay up to date on all our future
content